[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause] [Music]
the convoy started the day off before
dawn with fireworks in enfield nova
scotia trucker jody newell says he
decided to join to protest cross-border
vaccine mandates targeting his industry
we don't believe that the government
should be forcing us to do something we
don't want to do that could affect their
health samantha monaghan helped organize
the east coast leg of the protest she
says they're going to ottawa with a
message
to stop all mandates and to
just bring everybody together again and
open up cannon and make it free
by late morning the convoy arrived in
moncton with hundreds more turning out
in support
what is this about i think it's about
people coming together
and wanting to live free able to live
for him wanting to be able to make free
tell the truth
the atlantic province's trucking
association disapproves of the protest
convoy their executive director
jean-marc
is worried how it will affect an
industry struggling with recruitment
for the last two years we were seen as
heroes and a great industry and you know
essential and
so hopefully it won't leave too much of
a
you know negative impact
mark i should say but
you know
these things can can turn fast and look
at how it's escalated it's not even
about trucking anymore
the convoy picked up more supporters
just outside fredericton they'll
continue to rival zulu quebec where
they'll stop for the night the canadian
trucking alliance has estimated that as
many as 15 percent of truckers are not
vaccinated against covet 19. the convoy
is expected to arrive in ottawa on
saturday susan napoint global news
moncton